hey Vsauce Daniel here what is vsauce
vsauce is a popular educational YouTube
channel held by Michael Stevens or
Vsauce Michael or that guy who's always
doing the eyebrow things but the whole
time I was there I thought a lot about
video no I can do it I I can do it he
looks a little like this and a bit like
this and has a personal YouTube channel
named poop licker
888 but he doesn't use that anymore it
turns out there's a lot of things that
Vsauce isn't anymore if we assume for a
second that Vsauce is what it is
then Vsauce is a show called mindfield a
YouTube premium edutainment show
exploring pop psychology in a
professional broadcast half-hour format
in any given episode Michael will
explore a scientific subject typically
in the realm of psychology with a
particular focus on the science of
perception we learn that there's a stark
difference between what people think
they would do and what they actually do
the videos are neatly structured into
seasons and episodes with a clear
central thesis and tight consistent
branding it isn't just built like
television it looks feels and founds
like television right down to the
fabrication of conflict in a build up to
where commercial breaks would go this
forms an interesting contrast between
Vsauce and another similar channel
vsauce vsauce is a popular educational
YouTube channel helmed by Michael
Stevens in a given video Michael will
pop up and for about 10 minutes take the
viewer on a pinball exploration of a
scientific subject typically in the
realm of psychology with a particular
focus on the science of perception but
also a fascination with math and
astronomy a critic of Vsauce might
describe the format of a Vsauce video as
unfocused with each video taking its
subject matter less as a thesis and more
as an excuse to ramble for several
minutes of
vaguely related subjects a proponent of
Vsauce on the other hand might describe
the format of a Vsauce video as poetic
with each video taking its subject
matter less as a thesis and more as a
theme an opportunity to create a
free-form association between ideas that
share a commonality of language or an
overlap of consequences the video what
is the speed of dark is less about the
physics of photons and more about a
variety of subjects that all share an
intersection in the idea communicated in
the word dark this unstructured science
poetry forms an interesting contrast
between Vsauce and another similar
channel vsauce vsauce is a popular
variety YouTube channel held by Michael
Stevens in a given video Michael will
compile a rapid-fire freeform
presentation assembled around a common
seed idea like funny or interesting
images or bizarre consumer products a
format riddled with innuendo dick jokes
and cleavage the average Vsauce video
will skip across a couple dozen examples
in only a few minutes each be connected
to the next by pun or some other free
association word game with a particular
love for juvenile humor curious facts
and optical illusions this is the last
thing you will see before you die can
you find the cat but we should move on
to girls in costume tied up can you save
them
[Music]
this collection of curiosities in
innuendo forms an interesting contrast
between Vsauce and another similar
channel vsauce vsauce is a popular
gaming youtube channel held by michael
stevens in a given video marc michael
danielle chat Jeff and/or Angie will
perform stand-up comedy list video game
features compile Easter eggs make dick
jokes or all of the above
whether it's interesting places in world
of warcraft rocks in world of warcraft
that look like dicks or jokes about
characters in a world of warcraft posed
in sexually suggestive positions you can
find it on vsauce but that's not all did
I mention the stand-up comedy yes I did
you as dr. Mario are actually working at
a free clinic for the members of Jersey
Shore
yeah each level is one of the members of
Jersey Shore the last level
Snooki is covered in viral I've this is
in part the fascinating semantic
language of YouTube the word channel for
YouTube is borrowed from television
where a channel is synonymous with a
station and is largely station arrey a
television station is a fixed point a
portal through which the viewer watches
a flow of content as it moves past a
youtube channel on the other hand is
less like this channel and more like
this channel the common metaphor here is
flow a channel is a means of transport a
space that things pass through but a
youtube channel isn't a fixed point a
bench on which you watch the boats as
they sail past it's the whole thing you
can go to a YouTube channel and walk
along the metaphorical Bank by scrolling
all the way down you can travel from
here to here look Vic Vic and Stein
argued that language was
representational that there is a single
factual reality and it is the job of
language to describe these facts
language thus is like taking a picture
and the better a language the stronger
its underlying logic the clearer the
picture this brings up an interesting
contrast between the work of
vilkin Stein and the work of Ludwig
Wittgenstein ficken Stein argued that
the picture theory of language was
entirely wrong that words are not facts
are not fixed points in space but rather
words are how you use them in other
words use dictates meaning we have told
the story backwards and now let us tell
it forwards vsauce launched in 2010 was
a gaming channel that featured a broad
swath of video game based - dick jokes
and boob thumbnails that morphed into a
variety channel compiling interesting
videos images and curiosities with a
particular focus on dick jokes and boob
thumbnails as more and more videos or
produced the curiosities floated to the
top until Vsauce posted its first
self-contained educational video in July
2011 on the nature of explosions hey
Vsauce Michael here and today I'm in my
apartment okay look the point is that
today we're gonna talk about explosives
the rapid fire delivery remained but the
innuendo gradually took a backseat to
questions like why the earth has a moon
and the existentialism of atomic physics
in September 2012 the last of the
variety shows was posted with loot
episode 27 carrots sharpener it is most
likely this phase here that most people
think of when they say Vsauce this is
when they attracted most their 14
million subscribers this is when Bill
Nye made a guest appearance flash
forward to January 2017 Vsauce announced
the new premium show mindfield available
only to YouTube red subscribers while a
few monologue driven videos have been
released since then the last of them
which way is down was posted in November
2017 as we stand now in February 2019
the bank of Vsauce Channel it looks like
mindfield is vsauce but that's not the
all of it because that is simply from
now there is conceivably a future
snapshot of Vsauce where minefield is
itself just a
Stratham a phase the channel went
through in the same way the Vsauce
people conceptualize the freeform side
poetry is a stratum between mind field
and the hodgepodge of nonsense and dongs
that preceded it the same as lute and
image are a stratum between existential
psychology and painfully dated jokes
about Stuckey having sexually
transmitted infections the last level
Snooky it's covered in viral I there is
no real essential elemental Vsauce
because they are all Vsauce and as
always thanks for watching